when NASA thinks about aviation it
thinks big it's explained division is
famous for stunts like blowing through
the sound barrier with the x1 but the x
57 will be a rather more refined affair
it'll be fully electric essentially a
flying Tesla it has not two motors or
four by fourteen the top two are for
cruising but interestingly the 12
smaller motors along the wings leading
edges don't provide any thrust they just
get more air flowing over the wing to
generate extra lift during takeoffs and
this is how engineers it reminds this is
how they're going to test those things
before they before the plane takes off
next year with the with the latter truck
from Arrested Development the X plane
program is all part of NASA's plan to
reduce fuel use emissions and noise with
innovative aircraft design like check
out how skinny these wings are wings on
a typical plane are nice and fat because
they have to generate lots of lift to
get the bird off the ground but because
the X 57 has extra motor is pushing air
over the wings during takeoff Engineers
can scale down the surface area that
means less drag and nASA says that by
distributing power across so many motors
the plane will use 1/5 of the energy of
its gas guzzling cousins so imagine the
airport of the future it doesn't smell
or sound like hell on earth now if only
NASA could do something about those
damned baggage fees